fifteen seconds of the summit logo 45
second reveal of a title that has seven
letters in it like fire in powder
oh good Bellas narrating again new
filmmakers don't take creative license
to stop this vampire Sparkle bullsh
heavy-handed Romeo and Juliet reference
movie rips off the opens with everyone
on edge about a mysterious killer animal
that is obviously really a vampire thing
from the first twilight movie eight out
of the nine cars in this shot are silver
edward is addictive as fellow students
by parking over three available spaces
in a tiny parking lot you think Oh weird
they got a new actor to play Jacob it
wasn't shirtless all the time you know
anabolic steroids are really bad for you
well I'm just filling out Belen haha
gross Edward leaves Bella to talk with
Jacob in private but then stands close
enough for someone who doesn't even have
vampire hearing to eavesdrop on the
conversation I saw this the other day
and thought of you catch his bad dream
but not bad wigs Edward made it sound
like this conversation was gonna be
something deep but it was just a bunch
of idle chatter and a dreamcatcher at
the end come Jacob a gift I know it's
your birthday Bella you don't have to
exchange presents
honi Alice has one short flight of
stairs left but decides to jump over the
railing to get to Bella two seconds
faster teachers of the world when you
are mounting along with the bull film
you're showing your students it's time
to switch to a new bull film Edward
easily segues into an inappropriate
Romeo and Juliet analogy from a
discussion about hating birthdays Romeo
didn't kill his true love she killed
herself
Edward casually mentions the bull Tory
is if Bella is supposed to know what
that is and we don't kill conspicuously
then what about those vampires last
movie that ate the guy that played Santa
Claus at one time they were killing
conspicuously out the ass did you expect
to find a camera when you open Bella's
bag or were you just casually rummaging
around in it pop calls the kettle pale
paper cuts do not cause fam pyre
enticing blood drips of this nature that
appears to have a school lunch entirely
composed of pretzel balls
[Music]
falling down while running from your
failed teen romance cliche six minutes
of sulky from October to November the
same boat is on Bella's bed in the exact
same place either she never went to bed
this entire time or she's an expert in
placing things in the exact same
position every day also there are three
lamps in Bella's room in this shot and
more on the string here and another
hanging lamp and one more of the show at
least one more lamp over here oh look
another one back in the corner Oh God
another lamp and another string of lamps
here and one more down here on a little
shelf that's ten lamps in one teenage
girl's bedroom and two of those ten
lamps are actually strings of dozens of
little lamps the Cullens have Mack email
addresses hipsters also why are all here
messages to the Cullens being returned
with delivery failure I know they left
the area at least part of the reason is
so they don't smell her blood and want
to eat her but they can't still use
their dot any email address wherever
they're hiding out at they can't still
email this poor girl
there's no blood smell and email is
there it's not normal this behavior took
three months for Bella's dad to realize
her behavior wasn't normal
keep watch movie just decides on a whim
that Edward can appear as a mist to his
lover to warn her of danger raising the
question why he never did this before
now and of course why he never does it
again in future movies that's willing
embrace I'm cool hey thanks for giving
me your last name - man I appreciate did
the director just go with the throwing a
piece of pizza and it turns into a shop
- in midair transition that's a bold
choice
it's like the director got the gig by
going into the pitch meeting and blowing
everyone away with his creative vision
for never-before-seen bike shop
transition shots is that Samuli bella
recognizes some random shirtless Native
American team from a quarter-mile away
in a moving car hey Taylor Lautner's
back all right was he the whole movie
also I know we wanted a gratuitous Jacob
takes off his shirt shot but are we
really treating a fresh bleeding head
wound with a dirty sweaty t-shirt that a
teenage boy has been wearing while
riding dirt bikes all day these so
called bear attacks are all over the
news and yet Angela's friends decide
she's crazy for saying she saw a bear we
can we can check out Love spelled
backwards is love about face punch and
it's definitely January if there are
movies called love spelled backwards is
love and face punch I heard it sucks
movie that sucks cast judgment on fake
movie that sucks how can we squeeze this
Burger King product placement into the
movie I mean they paid us a bunch of
money oh I know trashed also the back is
turned so that the side with the logo is
facing the camera in this shot but in
the next shot the bang has been
delicately turned so as to reposition
the logo side of the bag to be facing
the camera again movie that apparently
sucks has way better dialogue than the
real movie it's in pontypool the shoe in
the hospital I think Bela was right
about those steroids she was joking
about earlier the movies apparently over
but no one's walking out of it Jake
your dad said man half this fucking
movie is just voiceover of Bela leaving
voicemails and writing letters to people
we can't be friends anymore instead of
just explaining the Bela who clearly
already knows about vampires that he's a
werewolf Jacob treats are like Encino
man and tries to hurt her feelings to
make her go away pseudo villain from the
first movie shows up in a field looking
for Bela just on the off chance she's
there why is there any reason he can't
do this on a regular basis you know have
conversations with her tell her he loves
her keep her from going insane he only
ever shows up to scold or warn her I
could had some weird missed vampire
version of Skype sex even then do it
already
lupus ex machina I wish I could explain
but I think literally it Jakob watches
the literally protocol after having
literally seen Jakob jump up to a room
like a cartoon now she begins to worry
about him jumping out of the window also
you live in a world where vampires exist
how many clues are gonna hit you over
the head that Jake's a werewolf before
you realize it Bella who has shown no
propensity for violence so far decides
now is the time to slap a naked dude in
a gang and because of what because he's
laughing also I guess werewolves have
all the composure of a drunken a sports
bar Bella I mean are you really gonna
have to wait until Jacob turns into a
fucking werewolf right in front of you
before you realize he's a fucking
werewolf wait what Jacobs a werewolf oh
that explains so much why does mist
Edward appeared a Warner of vampires and
other general risky behavior but not
show up with any warnings before she
goes and learns the secrets of the
werewolves his mortal enemies oh hey
Emily Sams Johnson don't stare at bugs
Sam we really have to go through
suspense about what's wrong with Emily
so that Bella doesn't stare just see
she's got horrible scars on her face
in fact why didn't you just say that on
the ride over here horribly scarred
person is turned around so that it's
some great reveal that they're scarred
cliche that's a ton of muffins was she
expecting all these dudes to show up to
the house why were they all going to
Jacobs house then sure was convenient
the bellman was there to see all that
one thing out if all they were doing was
grabbing a buddy for breakfast
vampires cuz they're fast yeah oh we're
faster dude the vampires we've seen in
these movies move at a blur do you have
better editing software to make you look
like you're faster than that
why did Jacob get a shirt after the
melee with Paul so your werewolf yeah
last time I checked
can't you find a way that just stopped
oh my god I watched horrible movies
before but this line might be the
stupidest line I've ever heard in my
life first off Bela who fell in love
with a vampire would probably never say
this second this line just begs the
movie to steal a page from the x---two
script and give its monster characters a
gay subtext it's not a lifestyle choice
Bela
movie steals a page from the x---two
script and gives its monster characters
a gaze up text also Lady Gaga lyrics
turned movie dialogue cliche question
born this way the only thing we do kill
vampires so what was Paul gonna do to
bellow when he roared raged into a
werewolf five minutes ago was he just
gonna give her a couple scars and say
good day madam
Victoria's here once I chased her all
the way to the Canadian border the other
night we had to stop there because
border patrol would have been pissed did
you not hear Jacob say they chased
Victoria all the way to the Canadian
border
Bella's memories of Edward also included
his Volvo xc60 Banshee mrs. Edward but
she misses the car too apparently a wolf
walked through here hopped on one leg
and managed to avoid making tracks
anywhere else what happened to the other
people who were hunting with Charlie and
Harry oh no not the water how can we
ever chase her now even though we were
shown clearly jumping into this water
earlier in the movie so Victoria jumped
into this water to escape werewolves but
she was somehow able to smell Bella
underwater and swam back you saw happen
Emily
Sam got angry lost it for a split second
and was standing too close what is it
with this standing too close bolt if
Emily had been a hundred feet away would
Sam have been able to not turn into a
werewolf or turn into a wolf but not
start a domestic abuse situation seems
like they're turning into a wolf part of
this equation is the problem not the
distance he'll never be able to take
that back just like everything else that
happens in the past what if I go mad at
you
well I'll be sure to run away the
correct distance whatever that is
seriously missed Edward
doesn't have anything to say about this
how come you couldn't smell it two
minutes ago when you drove up to the
house if the movies being consistent
Jakob should be a werewolf now because
they just can't help themselves I saw a
vision of you you've jumped off a cliff
so you came to the house for what reason
and you broke in - I can't see past you
and your pack of mutts so Alice's
ability to see the future is clouded
when it comes to werewolves just because
[Music]
why does Jacob pick up the phone at the
Swan house the whole reason is so he can
cryptically tell Edward bill as dad is
prepping for a funeral without
mentioning who it's for and so that ever
can break his phone and the movie can
continue this ridiculous charade of
comparing itself to Romeo and Juliet
he's gonna make a scene show himself to
the humans no when
he's gonna wait until near you he's
inadvertently giving us just enough time
to get there and stop him instead of
racing to the Volturi why doesn't Bella
jump off a cliff or otherwise try and
kill herself then miss tedward will show
up and he'll realize she's not dead case
closed
rather than taking advantage of the long
car ride to the city Alice waits until
they arrive and waste precious seconds
doling out much-needed instructions well
if she was coming to him by way of
dangerous dirt bike ride he could see
her coming right at least the mist
version of him could instead of
screaming or doing something logical
Bella just keeps running toward Edward
silently nipple bruised so again I ask
what's so special about Bella is she
gonna make the world a better place by
sulking in her bedroom telling people
not to give her presents on her birthday
basically being humorless teasing other
dudes because they don't match up to
Edward I mean had it not been for Alice
and Rosalie he wouldn't be even known
her life was in danger
Dakota Fanning isn't being precocious in
the scene I see nothing I know right
Alice's vision doesn't see the animated
singing animals that would accompany
this Future
this character represents how we all
look and feel while watching this movie
vampire series once again doesn't show
us all the cool that happens with
stories involving vampires so prospects
are not good that these two will make
out later oh you do okay so me keeping
you away you should stay the hell out of
my head how could a dword poke around in
Jacobs head but Alice can't see the
future when it comes to werewolves but
someone please map out the rules for
this series already
dear Alice this movie is still going on
can you believe it not one pie was in
this movie
just be done I was just buying a part
for the rabbit
you should really come take a ride when
it's done it's fast it's decent
I spent half the night talking to some
girl who's looking around the room to
see if there's somebody else who's more
important she should be talking to and
it's like I'm supposed to be all happy
because she's wearing a backpack through
the Cullens visit often
use the false news
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't see past you and your pack of
mutts don't get me you know what Bella
could have been doing all those months
Edward was away instead of sulking at
the window watching Hulu Plus you know
she's into shows like Jimmy Kimmel Live
and Shark Tank but with all the vampires
and werewolves in her life it's not
always easy to cut your favorite shows
as they air but with Hulu Plus all she
needs is an internet connection and
several months of clinical depression
due to an absent undead boyfriend head
to Hulu Plus calm slash sins today and
you too can have the power of your
favorite TV shows and movies on your
local device wherever your heart may
lead you there are these there's a
special two-week trial offer just for
our viewers that means you
so sign up at Hulu Plus comm slash
things today